on the internet today what's going on
what's going on man it's just um
she sent the little tweet out so I just
responded man it's all good though I'm
just so having to follow on the same day
so it's gonna be some some competition
you did what I'm saying but at the end
of the day my shout out shout out young
Sean would you ever do a record with a
young boy
I would do a record with them uh yeah I
do a song with the main tripping yeah
but it ain't really had nothing to do
with him though it started off with dirt
I announced the album Dirk came and said
he was dropping on the same day then he
came while he said he was coming he
wasn't really in it you feel me he just
he just got in it you did what I'm
saying because he wouldn't drop on the
same day it's it's dirt at the end of
the day like man it's just it's just
competition man y'all can get the album
man Soldier season you know I'm saying
but he moved it but he put aside he
pushing they back though so I ain't even
tripping I saw you thanked him or you
shouted him out I shot him out that's a
real [__] [__] like you know what I'm
saying if you see him on the internet
tweaking obviously it means something to
me even I don't know 100 of the reason
why he did it but he did it you feel
what I'm saying I saw [__] I respect